[音楽]
プー
グー
[音楽]
今日はシリア世代を代表してこちらになってまいりました
先ほどはパフォーマンスですから私の話は大変地味なお話にあります
さて今日皆さんいらっしゃるこの場所
住所ご存知ですか
ここは
港区六本木7丁目22番の1号です
港区ですみんな得する港区です
[拍手]
かつて港区長をやっておりましたのでいろんな方とお話をするときに
港区は財政抱くでいいですね
港区は公園がたくさんあって快適な環境で人口がたくさん増えていいですね言われます
ところが港区長就任時に専念
港区は多くの借金を抱えていました
現在港区は人口25万ですけれども私が就任した
2000年は人口が18万人でした
ということで港区長に就任した時に
頭を抱えましたそして解決策を
いらし人口回復再生債権ということで
港区の v 字回復を成し遂げました
この分一回復をさせた
その実現可能にした制作設計
それが何だったんでしょうか
先ほどご紹介ございました私本職は建築家です
ということで従来にない政治家の発想でない方法を色々考えました
区民の皆さんと制作の課題をつなぐ
そのせっ架け橋の設計をいたしました
その制作の設計の方法論について
ご紹介を致します大きく3つあります
まず最初に建築家的方法のそれから2番目研究者的方法論
3番目異文化理解です
実は
3度の海外留学の一つはフルブライト留学なんですけれども
3度の海外留学で
得たいろいろな
内容をですね使ってこういった設計方法論を考えました
まずその1番目の建築家的な発想ろ方法論ですけれども
建築家私は本職建築家ですからその発想がクリエイターなんです
つまり全国で例のないことを色々考えました
前例がありませんと発言する幹部を光つけました
そして日本発というようないろいろな政策を考え出しました
2番目の研究者的方法論ですけれども
データをたくさん集めそれを分析しその特徴を見いだし
解決の道筋を見つけるそういう方法論です
3番目の異文化理解です
アメリカへ留学中いろんな国からの留学生がいます
な文化的な背景やことがありますで冷静な議論をしてそして解決の道筋をつくっていく
いわゆるディベートの方法論です
話変わりまして港区の
財政等の状況をご紹介いたします
まず最初の頭ですこれは2000年度の23区の予算の財源別割合を示した図です
一番下の卵ですけれどもこれは23区平均ですが
各空デー
財源を借金に頼ったです
一番下に書いてありますけれども23型金で14.6%でした
さあ上から3つ目見てください港区です
いいですか
借金に通ったりつ
16.2%ですものすごい数ですねもうすぐ比率ですね
この頭は1990年代港区の人口の胴体と税収の変化を示した
ウズです
ご覧の通り90年代前半皆とか人口がどんどんどんどん減りました
したがって税収もどんどん減りました90年代の後半から徐々に人口回復をしそして
税収も回復していくかということがお分かりいただけます
この頭は港区の財政状況の推移を示した図ですが私が港区長に就任した時と
退任する時の
借金と貯金の数字を表したものです
私が港区長に就任したとき
借金は550億円ありました
職員は435億円です
4年を解任したとき
借金は400億に減らしました
そして貯金を800億に増やしました
つまり私が皆特徴の間
借金を返すことが私の大きな仕事だったわけです
この諏訪
2000年と2005年の23区の
総資産の変化とそれから土木し3度牧師さんというのは公共施設の建築ですね
から登録公園といった土木資産の総額の変化を示した図です
これは私自身で作りましたが
ご覧いただけますと港区は5年間で
総資産を800億近く増やしましたそれから土木史さん
恒久施設とか道路公園ですねこれを600億円近く増やしました
23区の中で港区が一番増えました増えましたても増やしました
さあ
噺家ありますけれども
私は
政治家という仕事でまったく関心がございませんでしたけれども2000年の港区長選
のわずか1ヶ月前ですけれども当時の港区長から後継者として港区長選に出馬して
ほしいと要請を受けました
びっくりしましたね当然のことですけど座は皆さんだって突然
政治家思考でもない人が突然頼まれたらびっくりしますよね
でもまぁ
フルブライトどう世話になった恩返しという気持ちで要請を受け
な特徴に当選をして港区長に就任しました
就任してびっくりしたことがたくさんあります
その一つをご紹介します
実は皆特徴を証明する証明書って何もないんです
皆さんもし会社員であれば社員証というのを持ちですね
学生さんだったらは学生所を持ちですよねいわゆる id カードです
みんな特徴は ig カードがないんです
もし併殺感から呼び止められて職務質問された時に
いや私は皆特徴ですって言っても消滅琢磨は何にもないんです
お顔を覚えてもらうしかないんです
だから顔パスなんですでですね待っているつもりはないんですけれどもそういうことで
驚いた次第
すっ
3度の海外留学で体験をしたことでその内容ベースに
永作実現という新たなパスを作ることができました
大きく3つあります
まず1つはコンバージョンという手法です
どういうことかと言いますと
従前の構造体をそのままにして内装を変えて新しい施設に作り替えるという方法なん
ですつまり
喜善既存の建築領土転換ということです
これは実は欧米にはたくさんあります例えば
へい墓所を
集合住宅に変えたり刑務所をホテルに変えたり
オフィスを
老人ホームに変えたりたーーーくさん例があります
私は留学中そういったものをたくさん見てきましたのでそういった例を参考にしまして
コンバージョンをたくさんやりました特に福祉の政策は政治会談の中でも一番大きな
重要な分野です
このコンバージョンは2つ特徴があります
財政そして環境に優しいということです
財政に優しいということか
新築をするよりコンバージョンの方が
構造体そのまま使い続けますから
半分の予算でできますそれから環境に優しいというのは構造体そのままなが開く使い
続けますから当然環境に優しいということになります
これは文字通り建築家的発想です
3つ事例があります
廃校になって小学校を
今でもニーズがたくさんありますけど老人ホーム
児童施設作り変えました
ケッチを見てくださいこれは具体的に赤坂の木川小学校
コンバージョンして特別養護老人ホームと児童施設にした例です
上に屋上の上にプールがあるんであーなんか小学校かなぁって分かりになるかもしれ
ませんけれども
これは面積が8000平方メートルあります
これをもし解体して新築するとしたらさっき申し上げたようなことでものすごいお金は
かかります解体するだけで大変なお金があります
開会すると8000平方メートルですから約1万トンのコンクリートのゴミが出ます
実は周りが道路が狭いですから5トンのダンプカーを
使って1万トンのコンクリートのゴミを捨てるとすると
に旋回ダンプカーが行ったり来たりするわけですね
そうすると騒音振動交通渋滞
ご近所にものすごく迷惑かけます
構造体そのまま使ったということで
そういう名は書かなかったその環境にやさしい事業になったということです
これはまさに建築家的発想です話変わりますけれども今申し上げたように
5周辺が狭い道路ず田中がたくさんあります幅員6m 東京にはこんな道をたくさん
あります
トランプ大統領は日本人はもっとアメリカ製の自動車を帰って主張していますけれども
トランプ大統領来日したらぜひこの日か小学校の前を通っていただきたいと思うんです
ね
おそらく大統領専用車こことを得ませんこういう道路が日本にたくさんあるということ
ですね
じゃあ二番目の例ですはい
した降雪質屋を女性の人権相談施設に作り変えました
いわゆるドメスティック by はセクシュアルハラスメントそういった相談にカーブ
した施設を作りました
多くの方に使っていただきましたそれから廃止になった幼稚園を子育てサポート
センターという新しいタイプの施設に作り変えました
これは日本はずですまあ=保育園と思っていただければ結構です
そういったことでやりましたそれから3番目です pfi
プラベパイナースイニシアティブ
ます
いわゆる民間活力を使って特別養護老人ホームと障害者の雪建設をやりました
でこれは1円も使わず
民間の事業者の方に41億円の施設をつくっていただいたんです
その方法は港区の土地をタダでお菓子ますから50年間お貸ししますから自分でせ作っ
て運営してください
そういうアレ形で皆どこは1円も使わずこの施設を作りました
それから3番目住宅の縁制度という制度なんですが皆とこだったくさんオフィス作って
います
オフィスだらけになりますということでオフィスを創るなら
住宅合わせて作れという制度を作りました
港区の住宅現在約10万個ありますけれどもそのうちの20%がこの制度で開発事業者
の方に作って頂いた
住宅です
その結果住宅が増えん人口が増え税収が増えたということです
ちなみに一つの礼を申し上げますけれども新幹線のし長い
品川駅ですこれ実は港区ですけれども品川駅今度気をつけて見ていただけたらと思うん
ですがホームの日住宅があります
これ
jr東海の社宅です jr東海品川駅のオフィスを作る時をお願いして住宅作って
もらいました
ホームの上です
社員は
仕事場と住まいが側なんで非常に助かったということで好評だと聞いております
4番目
港区のこれ区立芝公園なんですけれども
市民産駒で作りましたみんなとこはお金がありませんから
周辺の小中学生にお願いして公園のスケッチを変えてもらいました
そして花を植えてもらいました木を植えてもらいました本来だったらお金があれば専門
の業者さんに設計をお願いして専門の業者さんに作ってもらう
だけど区民の皆さんに参加いただいてこの公園をつくりましたそのプロセスが高い評価
をいただいて
緑の大賞を受賞しましたちなみに下に撮影禁止と書いてありますけれどみんな特徴が
私自身に許可を出して私がこの写真を撮りました
さあ皆さん皆さんの専門分野なんでしょうか
在学ですか文学ですか物理学ですか
近い将来皆さんが学んだことを
大いにでその分野で活用していただいて大成功することを期待しますありがとうござい
ました
[拍手]
[音楽]